foreign
[Music]
the legendary Animation Studio Pixar
confirmed intentions for a sequel to the
highly lauded animated movie Inside Out
the announcement took place during the
Studio's d23 display which showcased
developments from its live action as
well as visual effects chalkboards while
talk of an inside out sequel got
underway in 2015. director Peter doctor
originally rejected the idea
reconfirming his commitment to only
producing original movies like inside
out notwithstanding by the very next
year doctor and Pixar were seriously
considering the concept of a sequel
Inside Out describes the story of Riley
a young girl dislocated from her Midwest
lifestyle and forcibly relocated to San
Francisco along with her emotional
states Joy sadness anger disgust and
fear the emotional states live and work
in the head office Riley's mental
monitoring facility where they support
her in trying to navigate everyday
existence as Riley and her emotional
states adjust to their brand new life in
San Francisco Anarchy Reigns in head
office Riley's primary and most
significant feeling Joy attempts to keep
things exciting but the emotional states
totally disagree regarding how to best
explore a different town apartment and
classroom behind the scenes there have
supposedly been some adjustments during
the d23 Expo it was publicly stated that
Amy Poehler will return to the screen
with her position as joy in inside out
too but at least one or two of her
fellow voice casting crew are not going
to return due to some kind of wage
disparity rumor is circulating that Bill
Hader and Mindy Kalin will not be
reprising their their roles as fear and
disgust we also don't have any official
confirmation that Phyllis Smith and
Lewis Black Will reprise their specific
roles as sadness and anger in the sequel
either Kelsey Mann a 13-year Pixar
worker will direct the animation movie
an inside out author Meg Le fove will
come back to jot down the new screenplay
the official statement also publicly
revealed that Riley will be a young teen
in the sequel instead of the 11 year old
we met in the initial movie it was
disclosed that there would be new
emotional responses than inside out too
but not much else is defined regarding
them yet inside out really is an
outstanding movie and viewers are
thrilled that Pixar is producing a
sequel the audience was also shown some
recorded footage and screenplays which
appear to be absolutely fantastic
Riley's growth and development and the
group's confrontations with new emotions
open up a universe of interesting
opportunity communities everyone is
enthusiastic about it Amy Poehler who
got to play Joy in Inside Out revealed
that the forthcoming Pixar movie is
scheduled to be released on June 14
2024. the sequel has big shoes to fill
as Inside Out was among the year's
biggest blockbuster movies when it made
its debut in 2015. it won the best
animated movie at the Academy Awards as
well as best animated showcase at the
Golden Globes
foreign
[Music]